i've done a whole press tour where all i
do is live i don't think i could ever
have imagined it as being so well
received i'm a big fan of tom and those
movies and andrews well i was just
waiting to see if toby was gonna do it
and if toby was gonna do it and i i was
like well i have no choice i follow toby
to the end of the earth to get to be
there with these guys in their suits
whether it was like dancing around or
playing around in scenes and improving
yeah i don't know how to put it other
than just like this really loving fun
creative experience that i was just like
sitting in gratitude every day it was
very daunting because we were a long way
into shooting before you guys showed up
the date of the other spidermans are
coming was etched on my calendar and i
was getting closer and closer and closer
and you know the closer and closer i got
the more and more nervous i was but it
was an amazing experience and from day
one it was a roller coaster that i
didn't want to get off from you cracking
toby's back to coming up with the idea
of pointing at us like it was all stuff
that we came up with on the day and it
was just a lot of fun to be able to play
with three guys in spider-man suits